joining me now for an Ingram angle
exclusive dr. Drew Pinsky oh my god
Akhter to the stars you love that I do
not like that thank you for not reading
my okay what turns a helicopter
obsessive parent good you and I both
know them into a criminal you know what
boiling a frog you know you don't
realize you're getting into it and I
think you'll appreciate this when you
look at the coddling of the American
mind of the collie the American child
all roads lead to narcissism really
we've had a narcissistic turn in this
country for the last 30 to 50 years when
I first started working in a psychiatric
hospital I saw all kinds of different
personality disorder diagnostic
spectrums Brown the mid 90s cluster B
was always saw a hundred percent of the
time it's no sorry sociopath narcissist
borderline and if you are a parent your
child is an extension of you and you
cannot stand to see them uncomfortable
and so you have to save them from every
discomfort what their achievements are
are your achievements you have to make
sure they achieve it's a it's a freaking
mess well it's it's part of the problem
is that parents see their kids as status
symbols to extension of their right so
it's so you hear Janet down the street
her daughter's a lacrosse player she got
a full ride to do we got a joke eight
it's like trying to figure out you know
you know the right grammar structure on
a piece of paper and struggling like
what did I do wrong and then they say
there's got to be a shortcut there's got
to be a way I can get through this right
and then you've got a guy like that I
was in this image here who said tells
you it's a game which it is it's a
broken gam and a games have solutions
and if you just follow his advice you
can figure out the best way into that
what I love one of things I love about
this story though is that they've chosen
to to use the best sort of strategies of
Thurston Howell you know what I mean the
real ones have a white privilege an
old-school kinds of behaviors then they
use thirst and Howl's mechanisms top to
bottom here and how they could not have
felt guilty about it I can understand
and I'll tell you well or the thing that
has me and sense or these imagine their
physicians if not physician these
psychologists we do our address that's
the angle talk about them which is that
they somebody is doing neuropsychiatric
testing on these kids and falsely
measuring them to have some sort of
disorder that gives them extra time on
the
that is unconscionable ADHD or anxiety
disorder name whatever it might be it is
okay I'm incensed by this this is right
well that's that's an issue and there
are people with real disabilities there
are going to use help yes absolutely so
anytime we know every time they get I
hope people gonna go and just like every
time somebody gets into elite school
there you go how did you get in every
time a kid needs real help
Ferb's a little extra time on their
tests whatever it might be people are
gonna book a skew do you think we have
too many anxiety pets on planes that's
why I really wanted you to come here
tonight peacocks peacocks we have jumped
the shark fully I mean really I mean
honestly people are abusing that I mean
it's ABA ABA regulations allow you to
bring any manner of animal almost on a
plane and the if you use them as an
ottoman when you're in the bulkan see so
much it's going on pilgrim and his foot
in the door and hates me those are the
two things it tastes me I'm special and
I got my foot in the door and here it
comes for everybody else isn't it good
to let your kids and it's hard to jail
them fail I literally say that I think I
say this to my kids at least once a week
I have a twelve and a half year old ten
and eight and you don't want to do your
homework okay yes good luck have fun
with I said you're not don't look at me
to bail you out I was really wrong kids
on that stuff Jonathan he doesn't what
called the the colleague of the American
Mind where he goes over oh yeah and it's
well done but I told my kids things like
you want to you want to do drugs alcohol
go ahead go ahead try not bad not just
make sure the axe comes down comes down
hard god help you if there's an adult
giving you that alcohol because I will
call the sheriff's I was standing the
lawn laughing my butt off well I have
those parents hold on that coddled kids
crumble they crumble they come because
they're always waiting for the safety
nets we're the problem the parents not
the kids we're the problem and if we
don't let kids have
struggle with the misery of life they
don't develop grit they don't develop
regulations are resilient and they don't
do well I son the other other day said
mom I'm bored was a beautiful day good I
said go pick up a broom yeah I'm bored
pick a pick up a broom that did garage
says take the garage
it's so great to have you on thank you
the narcissistic personality traits
we've standard we've had a turn people
keep asking why is this happening that's
why it's happening we we have this
narcissistic turn but you and I could go
on we just talked about with Bill
Clinton number eight on the radio a long
time ago but now we've all sort of
drifted we will look at this like
tobacco one day I believe look at how
I'm holding up a screen we will look at
that as too bad my kids don't have
phones either good that's good
thank you so much